[музика]
вітаємо і Ласкаво просимо на Європу У
фокусі Ми раді що ви приєдналися до
нас Взимку коли погодні умови
погіршуються подорож через Середземне
море до Європи стає все більш
небезпечною для
мігрантів так званий Балканський
сухопутний маршрут - це менш ризикована
подру
серце цього шляху Сербія країна яка
межує з країною членом Європейського
Союзу Угорщиною у сербському прикордону
в місті суботіца мігранти шукають шляхи
для перетину кордону Багато з них
покладається на допомогу нелегальних
переправників сербські прикордонники
посилили контроль у цьому районі
оскільки незаконне переправлення людей
стало прибутковою справою для
банд екіпіровані Та добре озброєні Райко
та його колеги вирушають на
тлювання сьогоднішня місія знайти
незаконних переправників і вилучити у
них зброю у лісах на сербсько-угорському
кордоні ми прямуємо до місця в лісі яке
називаємо табором Омара зм'ям одного з
центральних діячів Чиє ім'я постійно
згадується Омар один з головних
переправників
тут Зараз ми зупинимося і звідси
підійдемо до табору
пішки і перевіримо Хто там
є це гра у кішки мишки у сербських
лісах переправники та мігранти
переховуються часто поліція знаходить
лише їхні
сліди
ці Куя це порожня коробка від набоїв
кулім67 для штурмових винтівок
Македонського виробництва про що можна
прочитати ось
тут раптово поліцейські
насторожуються здається щось
помітили Вони повністю
зосереджені останнім часом ситуація стає
дедалі
небезпечнішою багато переправників
озброєні і входять до складу злочинних
угруповань поліція з обережністю
наближається до вказаного
місця воно виглядає безлюдним ніяких
ознак розшукуваного переправника Омара
але за кілька метрів далі вони знаходять
двох наляканих біженців А ви говорите
англійською
Ці чоловіки із
Сирії Звідки
ви Сирії з Туреччини в Німеччину до
родини поліція обшукує їх Вони не
знаходять жодних підозрілих предметів чи
зброї машина забирає цих двох щоб
відвести їх назад до табору для біженців
на цьому їхня подорож закінчилася але
багато хто буде продовжувати спроби
платячи по кілька тисяч євро і віддаючи
свою долю у руки
переправників сербський журналіст Саша
драгойл роками досліджує нелегальне
переправлення людей він розповідає Що
мароканська та афганська банди поділили
між собою цей Підпільний
ринок ось тут ви можете бачити члена
аганської банди
40359 Вони часто використовують цей знак
у своїх відео
І дійсно не бояться
хизуватися ця ситуація вже давно вийшла
з-під контролю коли йдеться саме про
нагромадження автоматів Калашникова в
прикордонній зоні без жодного контролю і
тоді люди гинуть і це для мене червоний
прапор червона лінія Я думаю що з цим
треба боротися належним
чином але банди відчувають себе сильними
і непереможними як показують ці
фотографії тут вони позують на даху
поліцейської Маши
А ось так вони переправляють мігрантів
через прикордонні
паркани самі ж переправники викладають
такі
відеомережу як своєрідну рекламу своїх
послуг полювання на нелегальних
переправників на сербсько-угорському
кордоні триває щойно надійшла нова
вказівка про підозрілий рух повідомили
по
рації Райко наказує команді
вирушати зараз трохи труситиме
тримайтеся
міцніше вони знаходять тайбір який Схоже
хтось поспіхом
покинув це зарядний пристрій для рації
ми часто знаходимо такі речі і їх
конфісковуємо Вони використовують рацію
щоб попереджати
дру за кілька метрів поліція знаходить
драбини а незабаром і
людей Вони ховалися у
лісі усю групу беруть під
арешт поліція ще має з'ясувати чи є
серед них нелегальні
[оплески]
переправники сьогодні Райко та його
команда не спіймали омара цю мережу
переправників важко викрити багато
нелегальних переправників залишаються на
волі і міцно тримають цю прикордонну
територію у своїх
руках війна в Україні триває вже третій
календарний рік і Росія досі контролює
частину території України на південному
сході український Контрнаступ проти
російських загарбників триває але поки
що успіхи незначні і вирішального
прориву ще не
відбулося разом із тим украї стрімко
зростає кількість людей з ампутаціями
багато солдатів втратили кінцівки в
боях Костя кашула не шукає співчуття Він
отримав важке поранення на передовій і
зараз пристосовується до нового життя
чоловік каже що бачить своє життя
сповненим
можливостей масовий туризм може бути Як
прокляттям так і благословенням
середньовічне місто Котор у Чорногорії
побачило обидва ці боки
щороку сотні тисяч людей приваблює
красавц об'єкту всесвітньої спадщини
Юнеско що стимулює місцеву економіку і
сприяє процвітанню туристичної
індустрії Але разом із тим як туристи з
крузнихлендерів продовжують прибувати до
которської бухти вчені такі як дарко
ковачевич б'ють насполох кораблі сильно
навантажуютьце історичний порт особливо
узбережжя та тутешню делікатну
екосистему Норвегія має найдовшу в
Європі берегову лінію а фйорди-
найпопулярніший туристичний об'єкт
країни
гейрангерфорд один з вражаючих об'єктів
всесвітньої спадщини Юнеско який
приваблює все більшу кількість пасажирів
круїзних лайнерів але круїзна індустрія
має величезний вплив на довкілля
парламент Норвегії прийняв резолюцію про
декарбанізацію фйордів з 2026 року судна
у фійордах Світової спадщини повинні
бути без
викидів кораблі що викидають никові гази
не допускатимуться хід буде дозволений
лише суднам що працюють на
альтернативних видах палива Дехто вважає
що це виклик з яким буде важко
впоратися
величні гори що здіймаються з глибокої
синьої води пейзаж фіордів на західному
узбережжі Норвегії вражає своєю
красою цей унікальний природний ландшафт
приваблює туристів із усього
світу багато хто найбільше хоче побачити
гейрангерфіорд Франк Оле бонсексен
стежить за тим щоб гігантські круїзні
лайнери без проблем могли
пришвартуватися
для нас тих хто тут живе круїзні лайнери
- це наш хліб Неважливо чи працюємо ми в
порту чи катаємо туристів на
човнах багато людей тут живуть завдяки
туризму і не мають іншої альтернативи
щойно Корабель пришвартувався туристи
стікаються до села штовхаючись між
сувенірними крамничками
ресторанами і мальовничими оглядовими
майданчиками близько 400 000 круїзних
туристів відвідують це щороку але тепер
уряд Норвегії хоче різко скоротити їхню
кількість і перш за все припинити
забруднення спричинене дизельним паливом
для суден починаючи з 2026 року суднам
які працюють на цьому виді палива більше
не дозволять швартуватися у цих
водах у круїзних лайнерів найвищий у
світі рівень викидів на одного пасажира
і на о кіломет
пробігу і вони забруднюють наші фійорди
саме тому всі партії вему парламенті
прийняли рішення про політику нульових
викидів для туристичної галузі це буде
величезним викликом оскільки більшість
круїзних лайнерів досі працюють на
дизельному паливі але є й винятки як от
юрібія пришвартована в іншому порту у
гейрангерфіорді у машинному відділенні
менеджер круїзного оператора демонструє
Гордість і відраду
компанії корабельні двигуни які працюють
на зрідженому природному газі зпг
це великий крок вперед тому що ми вперше
використовуємо паливо температура якого
не така як температура навколишнього
середовища воно фактично охолоджене і це
відкриває для нас можливість у
майбутньому перейти на так звані
альтернативні види палива тобто з
набагато нижчою вуглецевою інтенсивністю
це так би мовити перший крок на цьому
шляху заміна дизельного палива для судин
на ПГ означає значне скорочення
викидів це також економить енергію при
розміщенні та обслуговуванні на борту
оскільки каюти та басейни обігріваються
двигунами
судна але до повної відмови від
дизельного палива ще далеко як можна
побачити у рубці управління під час дуже
сильного вітру капітан може перемикати
системи одним натисканням кнопки якщо ви
класнете цим перемикачем судно більше не
спалюватиме зпг а повернеться до
спалювання дизельного палива що можливо
дасть нам трохи більший крутний момент
або реакцію швидший час реакції на
рушії це надсучасне судно Флагман
флоту його будівництво коштувало Близько
1 мільярда євро проте для норвезького
уряду цієї технології
недостатньо якщо вони хочуть заходити в
наші Фіорди Вони поставили не на того
коня тому що зпг далеко не без
викидів це дає можливе покращення на
20-25 в порівняно з іншими видами
викопного палива але цього
замало дотепер лише круїзні лайнери на
електричних двигунах як цей могли
заходити у фіорд без шкідливих
викидів але заряду цих величезних
батарей вистачає лише на 4отири години
після цього Корабель переходить на
зпг перші кроки до того щоб зробити
круїзні лайнери більш екологічними уже
зроблені Але у цієї технології попереду
довгий шлях і якщо уряд Норвегії
залишиться непохитним гейрангер
прийматиме значно менше туристів капітан
Порту вважає що це матиме негативний
вплив ми усвідомлюємо що потрібно щось
робити для
довкілля але це все почалося дуже
раптово і я не можу уявити
наслідки Я боюся за засоби до існування
тих хто живе в цих
фійордах
капітан Порту і багато жителів
сподіваються на перехідний період щоб
туристи могли продовжувати відвідувати
гейрангерфорд на кораблях найближчими
[музика]
роками Дозвольте познайомити вас з
унікальним колективом який базується
Великобританії усі його учасники мають
синдром дауна генетичне захворювання яке
може призводити як до психічних так і до
фізичних
проблем колектив називається дрех
синдром Королі та Королеви цього
дрехколективу демонструють свою
творчість і талант глядачам всього світу
за останні кілька років вони отримали
міжнародне визнання ми зустрілися з ними
в
Берліні дрех синдром відзначають свою
велику прем'єру у Берліні це перший у
Британії професійний дрех колектив У
якому грають люди із синдромом
[оплески]
Дауна
[музика]
під час виступу Я відчуваю що стаю
більше
собою Привіт Я Нік також відоми як
Нікіта Голд дама Нікіта
Голд я Адам Вайлд або ж леді merмерcр
леді merрc довольно лояльна леді вона
любить працювати І
красуватися Нік Адам та інші учасники
дрех синдром перевтілюються на сцені у
різні
образи для них це бунт проти суспільства
і заклик до більшої різноманітності та
інклюзії для людей з інвалідністю А ще
це дуже
весело з моменту створення гурту у 2018
році учасники об'їздили з гастролями
кілька
континентів вони також виступали на
знаменитому фестивалі гastonber і
знімалися для модного журналу
вок я танцюю вже 10 років я дуже люблю
танцювати
саме тому я хочу робити це весь
час люди із синдромом Дауна досі рідко
виступають на
сцені цей танцювальний колектив хоче
заохотити інших людей з інвалідністю до
занять улюбленою
[музика]
справою це було приголомшливо головне -
це те що ми можемо достукатися до людей
і показати себе саме цього ми і прагнемо
слово різноманітність звучить звідусіль
але Питання в тому де насправді можна
побачити як воно втілюється в життя і Я
ніколи раніше не бачив такого шоу
артисти дрех синдром виступають за
свободу
[музика]
самовираження Ну і що жщо Я чувак
переодягнений в жінку Це не має значення
Я просто живу своїм життям Я просто
заявляю про те що бути вільним це
нормально роби свою справу Роби те що
маєш робити і пам'ятай сяй як
зірка
роби свою справу звучить як послання до
якого варто дослухатися цього року
Дякуємо за перегляд і до зустрічі за
тиждень Бережіть
[музика]
себе